The year was 1770, and Europe marveled at a wonder of the age, the Mechanical Turk.
A chess-playing automaton, a marvel of clockwork and ingenuity that defeated the likes of Benjamin Franklin and Napoleon himself.
The crowds cheered, the newspapers raved, and inside that ornate cabinet, a man sat cramped and unseen,
pulling strings, moving pieces while the world believed in the illusion.
Fast forward to the modern office, and we've built our own version of the Turk.
Not a machine that plays chess, but humans who play work.
They sit in ergonomic chairs, fingers dancing across keyboards, voices murmuring in meetings,
all while the real game progress, innovation, anything that might actually move the needle happens somewhere else.
And here's the thing, you don't just stumble into this.
You don't wake up one day and think, oh, I'll be a human loading bar today.
No, this is a mastery, a discipline, a 10,000-hour pursuit of professional hibernation.
They call it the 10,000-hour rule of inaction.
Most people know Malcolm Gladwell's idea that true expertise takes 10,000 hours of deliberate practice.
But few realize the same principle applies to stagnation.
And let me tell you, stagnation is a craft.
It's the art of looking busy while doing nothing.
Of sitting in meetings where no one expects you to speak.
Of sending emails that no one reads.
Of turning a five-minute task into a three-week odyssey of Slack channels and PowerPoint decks.
The tools of the trade are simple, really.
First, there's the meeting cloak.
Volunteer for every meeting.
Why?
Because in a room full of people, no one notices when you're not contributing.
The bystander effect does the rest you're there, but you're not responsible.
Idges, part of the scenery.
Then, there's the semantic buffer.
Master the language of corporate fog.
Synergy.
Pivot.
Alignment.
String these words together, and suddenly, no one can tell if you've done anything or if you've done everything.
It's the linguistic equivalent of hiding in plain sight.
And if you're ever given a task that could be done in 10 minutes, the slow build strategy is your friend.
Turn it into an initiative.
Create a roadmap.
Schedule check-ins.
Before you know it, you've spent weeks talking about the work instead of actually doing it.
But the crown jewel.
The sunk cost career.
You've been at this job for five years.
You hate it.
But you stay.
Why?
Because leaving would mean admitting you've wasted time.
Because the Concord fallacy, remember that?
Tells you that quitting now would be like scrapping a half-built supersonic dream.
So you endure.
You become the human equivalent of a loading bar, spinning endlessly, never quite finishing.
And then, there's the bathroom refuge.
The ultimate master class.
Physically gone, but still available on slack.
The perfect fusion of absence and presence.
No one questions it.
No one cares.
You've reached the zenith of active inaction.
By the time you hit your ten-thousandth hour, something strange happens.
You stop being able to do anything else.
You've trained yourself out of motion.
Learned helplessness isn't just a phrase anymore.
It's your professional identity.
You're the office monument.
The human loading bar.
The person who looks like they're playing the game, but who's really just waiting for
the clock to run out.
And the best part?
You'll never risk success, because success means change, and change means leaving the
cabinet.
So you stay.
You perform.
You collect your dead hours.
To work hard is to risk success.
To master the dead hour is to ensure a lifetime of safe, predictable dissatisfaction.
And isn't that what we all really want?